good morning John today I want to delve
into a peculiar practice of that most
mysterious of cultures the American it's
a deeply illogical practice economically
troubling psychologically dubious I will
regularly give money to people who are
not asking for it I'm not required by a
lot to do this but I feel as if I should
and I don't know why I feel this way
I've recently discovered that I don't
know why I feel a lot of the ways that I
feel I'm kind of an insane person for
example I spend many of my afternoons
watching videos about goat sex and
fictional soccer team but anyway to
start off our discussion about tipping I
want to go into my personal rules which
are as it happens the best rules for how
to tell you are at a restaurant that has
a jar a dollar goes in the jar if I have
a dollar if I don't have a single then
you're screwed you sit down and someone
comes to you to bring you food and talk
to you that that person deserves at the
very minimum 15 percent but almost never
do they get 15 percent because there are
three ways that they can increase their
tip one good service - if I feel
particularly nice that day three the
math is difficult and so I round up my
personal inability to do math and my
head is probably responsible for my most
generous tips if at the end of step two
I have not gotten above two dollars per
person I give two dollars per person
leaving a twenty five percent tip on a
three dollar bill is not good - the next
thing after a deep psychological
investigation of my own inner self I
have figured out that what I would like
to be the reason for me giving tips is
that those people are making me happy so
I want to make them happy but there are
a lot of lesser motives that I believe
are in fact much more responsible
waitstaff make less than 50% of their
living off of their wages most of their
living is from tips so I would feel bad
also I live in a very small town and the
person who's waiting on me is probably
friends with someone who I'm friends
with and I don't want it getting around
that I'm a jerk face and I think the
number one reason why I do it is because
it's the thing to do more I think about
it the more I realize that pretty much
everything I do I do because it's the
thing to do and I don't know why the
thing to do is the thing to do with just
ease sometimes I feel like my entire
life is just one long string no that's
the thing to do good thing to do I don't
need you
I make my own things too I don't my
brain is encapsulated by this culture
and it makes me do all the things to do
not that I mind I mean most of things to
do it pretty cool now the reason why
tipping is supposed to be the thing to
do because we want to encourage good
service it is important to note that
this does not work things that influence
tip more than the quality of service
include the ethnicity of the waiter or
waitress the gender of the waiter or
waitress the weather outside on that
particular day the cost of the meal and
whether or not they've drawn a smiley
face on the cheque smiley face
interestingly raises the tip of
waitresses by 9% lowers the tip of
waiters by 3% WTF here's the thing about
tipping 96 percent of Americans do it
every single time but a lots of other
countries it's just not a thing that
gets done in fact in like Japan and
China it's considered insult in Europe
where there are service charges included
in the cheque higher wages and also like
medical care that's inexpensive or free
waiters and waitresses don't need tips
in order to be above the poverty line
the United States however we have this
idea that everything should be
controlled by the market which is how
the UK and the with television shows
like Qi and Doctor Who and we are stuck
with documentaries about fictional
apocalypses on the History Channel and
that is why tipping kills Time Lords
where how did I get here leave the most
interesting comment to win my Winnie the
Pooh stir John I will see you on Monday
when you celebrate our fifth anniversary
it's a wonderful life don't forget to be
awesome if you're in America don't
forget to tip at least $2 per seat